foreign
[Music]
young koviak and it's my pleasure today
to tell you about recent joint work that
was done at the broad Institute along
with Fritz obermeyer and Jacob Lemieux
so the context for today's talk is the
covid-19 pandemic and specifically the
fact that there's been this huge Global
effort to collect a lot of genomic
samples from covid-19 patients and so as
of a few days ago uh We've now collected
something like 13 million viral genomes
of SARS covet II and so this is really a
huge amount of data it's a very rich
data source and we've never done
anything like this right no one's ever
sequenced this many viral genomes and
we've never seen a virus evolve in real
time like this so from a scientific
point of view this is all very exciting
and given this kind of Rich data source
there are a number of more or less
ambitious questions we might try to ask
and answer including the following
questions so we might ask which
mutations are driving the pandemic
which variants or lineages are the most
fit
which newly emergent variants should we
be paying extra close attention to
which mutations are implicated in
immunescape
is there any evidence for epistasis or
interaction effects between different
mutations and so on and so forth
so before we jump into trying to see how
we might answer these questions let's
take a little let's take a closer look
at the data
so there are a number of ways to look at
this data right so what do we have right
we have millions of genomic samples and
we also know where the sample is taken
from let's say France or New Jersey or
what have you and we also know when the
sample was taken and so a lot of ways to
slice and dice this data and one useful
way is as is done here using this
visualization from next train so across
the horizontal axis we have time the
last six months and on the vertical axis
we have a varying frequency between zero
and a hundred percent and so you can see
here that at any given time
um you know there's a small number of
variants that are sort of the most
predominant ones in circulation and as
time goes on different variants sort of
outcompete other variants right so we
should see the sun of Rise and Fall
behavior and in the last six months it's
been various kinds of Omicron variants
but you know going back over two years
there's you know a rich sort of uh
history of different variants coming
into the picture and so any modeling
that we'd like to do should recapitulate
these kind of of Dynamics
if we zoom in a bit right the previous
slide was global data but if we zoom
into smaller regions like let's say New
Jersey or Japan then we start to see
that the data are actually quite
stochastic right so 13 million samples
is a lot but it's still you know only a
small fraction of the total number of
people that actually got coded um and so
you know there's a lot of uh there are a
lot of SARS copen2 genomes that we never
observe right we only observe some small
fraction of what's actually going on and
that's part of this reason for this
stochasticity but also of course
um you know viral infection is just a
stochastic process right two people
might be in a restaurant together for
half an hour and in some cases it'll
lead to a transmission event and in some
cases it won't right so there's this is
an inherent level of stochasticity in
this data right so here again plotted we
have something very similar to what we
had on the previous slide on horizontal
axis we have time and on the vertical
axis we have a fraction between zero and
one for a particular covet variant b117
and we see that you know over time the
sort of broader trend is that this
variant went up and then it went back
down right but you know if we different
regions experience different Behavior
right so for example this variant became
pretty prevalent already at the end of
2020 in for example California but it
didn't hit Japan until a few months
later right so as we zoom in further and
further into this data it becomes sort
of more and more stochastic and from one
time into the next there's sort of quite
a bit of stochasticity and we need our
modeling to take that kind of
Behavior into account
so these sort of considerations led us
to develop a method that we call
Bayesian viral allele selection or bevas
for short and at high level this
modeling and inference framework
consists of three parts so the first
part is of data representation so the
data representation that we'll be using
for our analysis is that of allele
frequency space so basically time series
curves like we saw on the previous um
on the previous slides so here an allele
uh refers to you know a non-synonymous
amino acid substitution so for some site
in the SARS covet 2 genome you either
have the original wukon a amino acid or
you have a substitution to something
else right and so we have these time
series curves that encode how these
allele frequencies go up and down in
different regions over time and that's
the sort of fundamental data type that
we'll be using to make inferences about
SARS covet 2.
so given that data representation the
second thing we need to specify is our
modeling approach and we're going to be
using a diffusion-based model and
particular we're going to do that within
a probabilistic modeling framework and
the nice thing about diffusion is that
it's inherently stochastic and so
that'll do a good job of being able to
account for some of the stochasticity
that we saw on the previous slide and
then finally the third thing is that
we'd like to explicitly assume in our
analysis that most alleles are neutral
right we're assuming that most of these
mutations actually don't have any effect
or at least have a very very small
effect on differential viral Fitness
right most these mutations effectively
don't matter and it's only a small
number of mutations that are driving the
kind of differences that we see that you
know lead to for example the fact that
one variant is out competing another
variant
so these last two points mainly the use
of diffusion models and this neutrality
assumption
um make it perhaps interesting to
reference the work of this famous
Japanese population geneticist who's
particularly active in the 60s and 70s
named uh Kimura motto and so he both you
know pioneered the use of uh diffusion
models but he's also known for
um emphasizing the degree to which lots
of mutations actually are neutral or
approximately neutral so there's a sense
in which this framework that we're
describing can be seen as a realization
of some of the ideas that he's best
known for so just worth pointing that
out for some additional historical
context
uh but you know let's unpack a bit more
of what this method does right so first
of all let's remind ourselves what
diffusion is so diffusion is something
that's pretty familiar to us in our
daily lives right so for example
whenever you make a hot cup of tea you
see diffusion in action here on this
slide we have a little experiment
someone's dropping colored dye into a
beaker of water and we see that you know
over the course of three still frames
here the little droplet is diffusing and
expanding so the cloud of dye expands
but it does sound a pretty complex and
stochastic way and if we were to repeat
this experiment many times under
identical conditions uh the cloud will
look a little bit different uh each time
right this sort of broader pattern would
be the same the cloud diffuses that word
but the details of where those little
wisps of blue go would look different
each time right so that's the stochastic
element that underlies diffusion but
there's also a deterministic component
that corresponds to the drift downward
right so in this case you know these
glasses are on planet Earth and there's
gravity and it points down and so these
clouds despite all this sort of little
turbulence and little complexities of
motion that we see if we zoom in tend to
drift downwards right so that's what
makes these kind of diffusion models
interesting for us they're a sort of
principled way of combining uh
stochastic motion with a deterministic
drift component and and in this extended
analogy this drift component is going to
be the
genetic selection effects right so any
allele frequency sort of if we zoom in
might be from one time into the next
might be going up or down
but the broader trend of that allele
frequency is going to be determined by
some underlying deterministic drift
component that corresponds to genetic
selection or the fitness of any
particular variant variant among the
landscape of currently circulating
variants
so let's just unpack that a bit more
we're going to describe viral infection
as a diffusion process so one of the
basic concepts in a epidemiology is the
basic reproduction number or not and so
what what this number basically encodes
is that if we have an infected
individual at time T they're going to
infect a certain number of people in the
next time step and this is in general
going to be a stochastic number of
people but on average let's say that
person infects three people then that
would mean that they have a basic
reproduction number of three and so it's
um this sort of on the other hand
there's some variance around not some
sort of distribution and we're going to
see sometimes we'll see four sometimes
we'll see two and it's being able to
account for this kind of stochasticity
that's going to be important in making
these diffusion models uh sort of
powerful enough to encode the actual
data that we represent
and so you know so far I've sort of just
talked about
um SARS cover 2 variants circling and
circulating in a population
but to really make this interesting we
want to connect these variants back down
to the genotype right so this genomic
surveillance data is very rich because
not only do we observe you know a sample
in a given place at a given time but we
actually know the genotype of each
sample right which alleles are present
and which are absent which mutations are
there and which mutations are not there
and so to connect genotype to phenotype
or Fitness we need to make a more
detailed assumption and we're going to
make a very simple assumption which is
that the basic reproduction number are
here depends on the genotype linearly
right so we introduced this Delta R term
that modulates the fitness up or down
note that in the following I'm going to
be using the words Fitness and basic
reproduction number and growth rate more
or less interchangeably it's just this
number R which encodes the sort of
relative strength of a given variant as
the outcompetes other variants that are
circulating
and so this Delta R term under this
linearity assumption is just going to be
given as a linear as a sum over capital
A many alleles in our actual analysis
we're going to have about 3 000 alleles
we introduced 3 000 selection
coefficients beta one for each amino
acid
and so as a consequence each variant is
going its Fitness or R is going to be
governed by basically a linear
combination of some small number of
selection coefficients corresponding to
those selection coefficients that
correspond to those mutations that are
actually that make up that particular
variant
okay so just quickly wrapping up on this
modeling and inference technique the
fourth word in in our technique is
selection based in viral allele
selection and this word choice refers to
a set of techniques called Bayesian
variable selection which is just a way
of imposing sparsity uh in our selection
coefficients beta right so this is how
our neutrality assumption sort of gets
encoded uh at the statistical level and
so what this means uh is that we're
going to assume that most selection
coefficients beta are strictly zero in
other words we're trying we're looking
at we're looking at those models which
um are parsimonious and we're going to
prefer solutions that are simple over
solutions that are complex and the
result of doing this will be a
statistical framework that tries to
balance data fit right trying to explain
all these time series of allele
frequencies by doing so with as few
non-zero betas possible and that's her
neutrality assumption gets encoded into
our statistical framework
so before we move on to actual results
let me just leave you with one final
analogy that kind of ties together how
this method works so imagine that you
observe a short video of diffusion in
100 glasses of water on a 3 000
dimensional planet
so the goal in in this context would be
to infer the direction of gravity right
we see a hundred little clouds of ink in
these 100 glasses of water and they all
look a little bit different but all of
them are are tending to drift downwards
and we want to watch we're given 100
video you know 100 such videos and we
want to infer that direction from
watching those videos and depending on
how noisy those videos are that might be
hard or easy but the point is that this
sort of diffusion model gives us a
principled way to sort of extract that
deterministic motion and uh you know be
able to look through all that
stochasticity and pull out the
interesting bit which is the
deterministic motion and in this analogy
the hundred glasses of water would be
the 100 regions in our analysis and the
3000 Dimensions would be the three
thousand alleles that we're looking at
in our actual genomic surveillance data
so before we move on to uh results from
actual data let me just briefly present
you with some simulation results right
so when you run such a complex model
it's good to see how well it does in an
idealized setting with simulated data so
what I've done here is run a number of
simulations where I sort of artificially
create a pandemic in silico and then I
see how well our technique vbas is able
to recover those small number of alleles
that are actually driving the Dynamics
in the simulated pandemic and I'm
comparing here against three other
methods you know for the details check
out the preprint but what I'd like to
sort of highlight here is a few things
so first of all in the horizontal axis
we have depicted the total number of
alleles in this each simulated pandemic
and in on the vertical axis we have some
Metric of success that basically encodes
how many of the true alleles that are
causal and that actually have Fitness
effects right identified by the
inference technique and so what you see
here are first of all that is the total
number of alleles increases this of
course becomes a much harder problem
because you know the hypothesis space
increases and it becomes harder to
identify the true alleles but as we go
from left to right and we collect more
data in this case data across more
regions then we do a better job and most
importantly our method bebas which is
denoted in blue here sort of does the
best across the board right so this
gives us hope that when we apply this
technique to real data we actually have
a good chance of extracting some of the
real on the underlying selection effects
so now moving on to uh our actual data
analysis from genomic surveillance data
provided by gissade so we did an
analysis on 6.9 million genomic
sequences collected from 128 different
regions through April 18th of this year
we looked at
2975 non-synonymous amino acid
substitutions
although you could easily look at more
if you were so inclined
and recall that our method sort of uh
delivers inferences at two levels right
so on the one hand we have this notion
of variance and so we get variant level
inferences for example we get this basic
reproduction number R we're going to
estimate that for each variant in our
data set but we're also going to get
amino acid level differences to begin
with let's just look at the uh
at the lineage or variant level
inferences so here I've extracted a few
kind of well-known variants on the left
we have their Pango designation and in
the second column we have the more
well-known who classification and in the
final column we have the growth rate or
Fitness
um that as estimated by our method bevas
rack rank from most fit lineages at the
top to the least fit lineages at the
bottom and we can see that this ordering
recapitulates the kind of observed
substitution dynamics that we observed
in the real pandemic right so for
example an alpha and beta have a
relatively small Fitness effect over the
original Wuhan a variant whereas Delta
has a substantially larger growth rate
advantage and finally some of the most
recent Omicron variants have the largest
growth rate Advantage observed thus far
and those of course are the variants
that have sort of dominated the recent
phase of the pandemic so this is nice to
see because it recapitulates what we
would have unexpected the same
zooming in a bit on those results we can
also ask just what are the top 20 panel
lineages as inferred by our model and
here they are and you can see they'll
have quite large Fitness advantages over
the original wukon a variant by a factor
of about seven or eight and all of these
are various subvariants of Omicron you
know ba5 has seen quite a bit of
attention in the Press recently but you
know these are results as of April 18th
but they are sort of broadly consistent
with what we observed afterwards so
that's also um good to see
okay so now let's quickly move on to
amino acid level inferences right so
recall that we introduced a 3 000
dimensional Vector of amino acid level
coefficients beta
and each of those coefficients
corresponds to a specific amino acid
substitution uh in the SARS Coba 2
genome and so we can display them
graphically as I've done here so along
the horizontal axis we have the SARS
covet 2 genome broken up into different
protein regions
and on the vertical axis we have the
inferred selection coefficient beta so
each Red Dot here corresponds to one
selection coefficient for one specific
amino acid location and first of all we
see that most of the red dots are near
zero right and that's as we would expect
given our neutrality assumption and
suddenly a relatively small number of
amino acid positions where there's a
non-negligible effect size and those
effects tend to Cluster in a few places
in particular a lot of them cluster in
the spike
or S protein which is not surprising
given the pivotal role that the spike
protein plays in uh viral entry into
human host cells so this sort of
recapitulates what we would have
expected and if you sort of take a
closer look at this you can see there
are a few other hot spots and some of
them are in sort of parts of the genome
where the biology is better
characterized and some of them are maybe
a bit more mysterious or hard to
understand but this all this just points
to the um
some of the advantages of this kind of
agnostic genome-wide analysis which is
that you know we we don't have to go in
with some specific hypothesis and let's
say only focus in on the S uh region of
the genome we can really just ask this
broad question which parts of the genome
seem to be contributing to uh uh the you
know differential viral Fitness and this
can help us identify hypotheses and
perhaps you know lead follow um you know
help prioritize experimental follow-up
in the lab and perhaps point to parts of
the genome that we're receiving less
attention
um before this
zooming in again again a bit on these um
uh amino acid level inferences here are
the top 10 hits as identified by our
model
and so you know there are no real
surprises here these mutations that I've
listed here are all kind of um are
mostly pretty well known and well
characterized by this point so for
example this d641g mutation was sort of
one of the early mutations that was
identified towards the beginning of the
pandemic as playing a role in
differential Fitness for some early
variants so it's good to see that kind
of thing recapitulated here in our
results and an interesting thing about
this Bayesian viral allele selection
approach that we're using is that we in
addition to getting you know inferences
on the actual selection coefficient beta
we also get an inter interpretable score
score called a pip or posterior
probability
um which is a score between zero and one
then encodes how much statistical
evidence there is that supports any one
of these given inferences and so that's
a useful way for us to sort of rank
these different hits but also gives us
some level some sort of notion of how
confident we should be so these top 10
hits for example all have a lot of
statistical evidence for them since they
have Pips that are very close to one at
least under our modeling assumptions
another way that we can display our
results is graphically like this so what
we have here in the left and right panel
is the structure of the S protein
and and in particular the S timer is
denoted with the yellow and blue
um you know 3D mesh frame whereas the
magenta bit is the ace2 receptor in
human cells which is sort of the main uh
viral entry point for SARS Coba 2 and
depicted in red are some of our top hits
right these are the amino acid residues
where our model thinks uh there's a lot
of selection pressure and if we zoom in
on the right we see that a lot of these
hits are actually in this interface
region between the ARP uh between the
spike trimer in particular the so-called
RBD region or receptor binding domain
and that H2 receptor so this is you know
what we would expect but it's nice to
see this kind of thing emerge from this
kind of agnostic genome-wide analysis
uh you know given that we have these
high dimensional inferences both at the
variant level and at the amino acid
level you know there's a lot of other
interesting kind of visualizations and
different ways that we can sort of
splice and dice our inference results
and here's uh one of them that I like so
across the horizontal axis we have time
uh basically months in the pandemic and
each Blue Dot here corresponds to one
SARS covet to lineage or variant and on
the vertical axis we have the Delta R
the sort of Fitness estimate or fitness
advantage as estimated by our method
Vivas and so you know one thing that's
immediately clear is that you see that
as you go from left to right and as time
increases the fitness advantage of these
lineages
is increasing right so the horizontal
position of each lineage or each Blue
Dot corresponds to when it first
appeared in the data it's birthday so to
speak and we see that you know a lot of
the most recent lineages of course are
the most fit which is not surprising but
one thing that's particularly
interesting in this figure is the
following so this figure the three
panels in this figure uh break down this
Delta R contribution according to the
different genomic regions right so the
leftmost figure corresponds to the
estimated Delta r that comes from
mutations in the sgn while the rightmost
figure encodes the Delta R difference
that comes from everything else side of
the estrogen right so we see broadly all
three figures have the same upward Trend
there's this interesting kind of
transition point
at the end of 2021 where the S Gene
Delta R contribution really jumps upward
by a large amount and that's pretty
interesting because that's sort of you
know it's around that time period where
Omicron came into the story and so this
sort of phase diagram is consistent with
the idea that you know ever since
Omicron and ever since you know late
last year we've sort of transitioned
into a immune Escape phase of the
pandemic where a lot of the differential
Fitness effects that we're seeing
between different variants is driven by
immunescape and as such mutations in the
S Gene are playing a particularly
important role in this phase of the
pandemic so it's nice to see that in
this kind of figure
so there are other kinds of analysis
that you can do with this kind of setup
I'd like to just highlight one and
that's doing a vaccination rate analysis
right so everything I described up to
now is just using genomic surveillance
data but we can also try to pull in
other sources of data so in particular
one has access to vaccination rates in
different regions and how that
vaccination rate has gone up over time
so we can imagine a model that is
similar to the model I described earlier
but now it has twice as many allele
selection coefficients we still have a
vector of allele level selection
coefficients beta that are going to be
assumed to be vaccination independent
but now we're going to introduce 3000
vaccination dependent effects Alpha that
are modulated by the time local and
region local vaccination rate which here
is denoted by five and then we can try
to infer beta and Alpha from the data
and in principle this is you know this
Opera this is quite difficult right
because we went from inferring say 3 000
coefficients to six thousand so this
sort of thing is hard to do given the
size of that hypothesis space
uh but the nice thing about the kind of
Bayesian framework that we're using that
also has underlying sparsity or
neutrality assumption is that it you
know this sort of thing things Still
Remains tractable and we're still going
to you know use our parsimony assumption
to favor Simple Solutions and the
strongest evidence that emerges from
this kind of analysis
for allele level uh dependence on
vaccination rates is in a interesting
residue in the spike protein called
n501 and so it appears from our analysis
that this the vaccination actually uh
confers differential protection against
this allele right so we know that
vaccinations of confer protection
against Cyrus covet to variants in
general but this analysis uh suggests
that there's sort of an additional
differential protection against uh those
variants that carry this particular
allele
so I'd like to quickly uh summarize so
the beginning of the talk we asked these
five high-level questions uh and so
let's sort of see how we did which of
these questions were we able to answer
with our method be best
and so I would argue that the first
three questions uh we did a pretty good
job so I put a red check mark so those
questions are which mutations are
driving the pandemic which variants are
the most fit we get a nice pip ranked
um
list of mutations so that's useful for
prioritizing experiments for example
we also get we have the ability to make
Fitness estimates for newly emergent or
putative uh variants that maybe don't
exist in the data at all or have only
barely been seen and that's relying on
the statistical sharing of strength that
we get by our linear fitness model so
that's useful
the next question was which mutations
are implicated in immunescape you know
with this analysis that I described in
the last slide this vaccination
dependent analysis we sort of get an
initial attempt of an answer at that
I've only put a sort of orange check
mark here to note that this is a you
know particularly difficult question to
answer using genomic surveillance data
right because
the vaccination data that we have is at
the population level right whereas what
we'd really like is to have vaccination
data at the uh patient level and we
would like for the the patient data to
then be connected to the genomic samples
and then it would be in principle easier
to make you know to do this kind of
analysis nevertheless uh we were able to
extract some insights using this
population uh level data so that's
interesting
and finally another interesting question
is is there evidence for epistasis so I
didn't go over this uh
previous slides but if you're interested
in this check out the preprint an
interesting thing about epistasis from
our point of view is you know once there
are many many uh mutations observed in
Sarasota so it becomes our very
difficult to answer questions about
apostasis since epistasis is a question
about how different mutations interact
and if you have thousands of mutations
then you have millions of possible
interaction effects but one nice thing
about our framework is that because we
have this sort of Bayesian sparsity
assumption at the
core of our model it's actually
tractable to try to answer some of these
questions and so some epistasis effects
May in fact you may be able to extract
certain epistasis effects from this kind
of data although doing so is quite hard
for a number of reasons including the
fact that you know most combinations of
alleles are just not present in the data
right we've seen thousands of variants
but we haven't seen the millions of
possible variants that one could have
right so it's still difficult to do this
but there is there is some tantalizing
evidence of epistasis in the genomic
surveillance data that we've analyzed so
if you're interested in that uh check
that out and more broadly if you're
interested in our work
um check out our preprint there's also a
open source library for bivas on GitHub
which is uh available to anyone who's
interested and in general please set
please feel free to ask me any questions
and thank you so much for your time